former FBI director robert mueller will
lead an investigation into the NFL's
handling of the Ray Rice domestic
violence case Muller was appointed by
league commissioner roger goodell who is
currently at the center of this story
and here's why their conflicting reports
of what the NFL and Goodell knew as well
as when they knew it the AP reported
yesterday that a law enforcement
official sent the league a video of
Rice's assault on his wife five months
ago and yet Goodell told CBS yesterday
that the NFL only saw the video this
week so which is it Goodell spoke to the
media about the domestic violence issue
yesterday he was at a Raleigh North
Carolina High School where he was
promoting the NFL's program to make
sports safer well that's always what you
want to make sure is that they
understand that we're trying to do the
right thing at all times when we make a
mistake we're honest about it and we're
open about it and say we're going to
work at it do better we were few weeks
ago that's when we improved our policies
in this area and we have more work to do
and we're going to keep listening and
keep learning and making sure that we're
doing the right thing for all our things
yeah it goes without saying that this is
an emotionally charged issue all you
have to do is watch Jerry Richardson the
owner of the Carolina Panthers he broke
down while accepting an award from the
echo foundation which promotes people
who are trying to make a difference
standing before you tonight I would be
remiss if I did not acknowledge an issue
weighing heavily on our sport high
society
when it comes to divest and domestic
violence my stance is not more than
difference I stand firmly against the
rest of domestic dramas plain and simple
now as far as the NFL's response we
heard two sides of the story from sports
agent leigh steinberg and former giants
player carl banks this is on
street-smarts yesterday I think everyone
knows that the NFL has the ability to
gain the access to things that they
think that's important to the game in
the security and the image of the league
so if it was amazing isn't worth the
peak and there have been no named storms
in the Atlantic for the first time since
1992 I guess that's a good thing
it feels really great to see Seattle
growing by leaps and bounds I'm Mike
medeiros vice president seattle for
delta by december delta will offered 95
peak day departures 233 destinations
making it Seattle's fastest growing
airline we will continue to expand our
offerings up and down the west coast
transcontinental and international
destinations Delta is the only carrier
that has either first or business on
every flight Wi-Fi on every domestic
flight from Seattle and seat back
entertainment on every long-haul
international flight delta employees
live and work in this area it's
important for us to be a part of the
community we've got